c'est simplement un appareil qui comme
un appareil photo prendre son
environnement et puis
le résultat c'est des images en 3d et
donc des images très précises c'est à
dire qu'on va pouvoir voir tous les
petits rouages tout ça et donc on peut
plusieurs positions et en assemblant ces
positions ça nous donne le bâtiment en
3d avec tous les éléments mécaniques
puis tous les éléments de structures
viennent de numériser les pièces pour
tout remettre dans l'ordi et commencer à
travailler pour le remplacement de steve
hill sera nécessaire et donc c'est parti
y'est on en a pour six mois de travaux
un gros chantier confié à une société
savoyarde spécialisée largement soutenu
par les gens du village
notre budget est bouclé pour l'aspect
restauration du téléphérique
donc on compte sur vous pour l'aspect
technique voilà on est un merci de votre
confiance tous suivent de près la
renaissance de leur trésor en
fournissant un maximum d'éléments pour
que les choses se fassent dans les
règles de l'art
nous on va également participer au
niveau des municipalités ont fourni des
poutres de chêne qui vont remplacer les
quelques unes qu'on doit changer qui
sont usés et donc c'est cdu chaînes
locales
[Musique]
tous ceux qui depuis des années avait
oeuvré pour éviter le pire en restaurant
par exemple les deux stations de départ
et d'arrivée du téléphérique n'en
reviennent pas de voir enfin leur projet
se concrétiser ah bah écoutez là vous
avez devant vous un président heureux
parce que
fut tant d'années que le projet est en
route
on arrive au ça se concrétise maintenant
c'est sûr que ça va aboutir à des bulles
et l'exploit technique des hommes du 19e
va prendre tout son sens 500 mètres de
long 2 100 mètres de dénivelé sans
moteur une savante construction de
poulies en bois et en fonte resté
quasiment intact le tout inspecter près
de cent trente ans plus tard grâce aux
technologies les plus pointues
c'est un contrôle par ultrasons c'est en
fait c'est le principe d'une échographie
sur une ferme en satin on envoie une
onde dans la ferraille qui réfléchit par
un potentiel défaut
et balla sur les deux dernières semaines
justement on a tout démonté le système
de machinerie des rouages les axes les
les points de fixation des câbles et
tout ça et nous avons même remplacer les
anciens câbles porteurs
la récup'et tous les rouages tous les
axes toute la partie métallique de la
machinerie et qu'on emmène chez loin en
atelier en savoie ou médian et pour
rénover tout ça et remettre à neuf
et c'est peu dire que la tonte est forte
le dernier paysan du hameau à avoir
utilisé le portelais n'a pas manqué une
miette du démontage
on a mis un trait en place et on a
accroché le vieux troll et le vieux cap
dans le truck
attirer les nouveaux câbles au bout des
lieux de vieux câbles ne vous avez vu
comme ça parce que yaya raciale oui ça
va les personnes qui est qu'ils ont fait
fonctionner à l'époque ce sera aussi au
moment où on pourra faire le faire
vraiment tourner
[Musique]
comme un clin d'oeil à l'histoire loi
sur seille qui s'était inspiré au 19ème
des techniques utilisées dans les
montagnes de savoie il fait aujourd'hui
renaître son téléphérique